Привіт мене звати Костя надаша я учениця
11-го класу і також лідер чугувського
учнівського
парламенту Ми почали вигадувати ідеї для
підтримки збройних сил України почали
знімати відео на цю тему почали робити
окопні свічки робили оберіги для
військових а для мене дуже важливо
підтримувати
дітей Ми з парламентом та кураторами
нашими придумували різні заходи для
дітей придумувала різні корисні поради
знімала для них відео щоб вони не падали
духом І також я надихаюся тим що мій
батько військовий і я хочу Таким чином
його
підтримати Я вважаю що такі люди як я як
мої друзі як наші куратори як всі Вся
активна молодь є дуже важливими людьми і
саме ми є майбутнім та поколінням
Перемоги